I want to start with a sincere
congratulations for doing the impossible
um but you've been talking all day about
yourself and now I'm going to change it
up
um I am curious uh what was it like
watching Creed 3 for the first time and
what notes did you give Michael I'm not
answering that bro I'm not answering
that yes that's crazy
I mean I I asked her what it was like
fantastic that's what it was like I I
was filled with um a lot of Pride for
for Mike uh
for Jonathan
for Tasha
for Felicia
um and and for for the young starter
everybody's about to meet that players
Amara
um but it was I was filled with it with
a with a deep deep deep sense of Pride
for all of them and my brother
um my baby brother who who wrote the
script
um in in uh along along with uh Zach
Balon who wrote King Richard I was just
proud of them all you know and and I
called Mike and told him
um I'm not gonna get into the knowledge
I'm just messing around but like uh I I
heard it turned out great it's still
working on it man but it's I think it's
it's a unique movie yeah I'm I'm curious
for for your career going forward you
have done these huge movies and I'm
curious if you're interested in um like
doing something like a secret Wars or
another big Marvel project or are you
interested in doing like a smaller more
personal film yeah you know what I mean
yeah I mean look bro I'm I I pray I have
a uh
you know um
oh I'm I'm a uh I'm a husband and a dad
now so I'm trying to live a long time
you know what I'm saying I hope to work
a long time
um and uh I love I love making movies it
brings me
it it fills me with um
a sense of joy that I hope every every
human can can find in their life and I
hope to make
I hope to I hope I can maintain that joy
and make more things of various sizes
um but truth be told like right like
right now I'm just focusing on this you
know and getting this done
um because it's because it's still a lot
of work to do before this comes out to
the world and um once that's over all my
[ __ ] and think about what's next uh one
of the things that I really commend you
on on both films is having a great
villain both times I feel like I
understand their motivation and I
believe in what they're saying for you
what's the secret in creating a great
villain
um
wow
um
I actually for me I don't see him as
villains like I've seen like like I
think antagonist is probably yeah no no
totally totally no no but I think that
word is fine like
I don't I don't try to govern people's
words you know I should have said
antagonists
but that's kind of like how I think
about him I think Obama Mash you know
this is a character that's going to come
in conflict with my protagonist you know
and and and it'd be interesting if they
want the same things you know you know
what I mean but but um but but because
of who they are and what shaped them
um they wanna they wanna they wanna they
wanna get those things in different ways
and their means you know uh their means
come in conflict with each other you
know and and it comes to a head you know
that's kind of like uh
um
how
movies are like or structured you know
um
uh
um
and and and I think like
you know Terminator 2 is a big
inspiration for this movie you know um
uh big time and and you think about what
what you know
um T1000 once and with Arnold
Schwarzenegger's robot once they both
want John Connor you know what I'm
saying like like but 21 Thousand wants
to kill him
Arnold Schwarzenegger character wants to
protect him you know you know that but
but that that's that's
you know that's the movie you know what
I'm you know what I'm saying and
um I I I look at it like like like like
that and
um
and also
um
trying to spend time with them not too
much you know what I'm saying but but
enough
that that you that you understand where
they're coming from
and um
and and that you believe you know like
like when I when I um when I make
threats you know yeah like like um you
know that's what makes Neymar I think so
cool in the books like he's in in most
run most publishing runs in him he's
very arrogant you know
um but but you also know he has the
capability to do what he's saying he's
gonna do you know like um he walks in
with his in his underwear and says hey
I'm gonna kill everybody you know but
you believe it you know because you know
he's capable of it you know um uh so so
we wanted to kind of bring that same
kind of that kind of the same kind of um
that same kind of swagger to the
Cinematic version of him you know but
also uh give it to give it the the
detail that you that you were
recognizing in a Black Panther movie I'm
curious I'm obsessed with the editing
process because that's where it all
comes together yeah we have some great
ones man like like um Michael sharper
Kelly Dixon gen Lane fantastic I want to
ask you a specific question though um
who what did you learn from early
friends and family screenings uh test
screenings yeah that impacted the
finished version of this man you asked
me some some detailed process questions
um what do we want what man let me think
about that what do we learn from early
friends and family screens that impacted
this
yeah
um
this movie was big it had a lot of
moving Parts uh
we delivered a uh did it the others
delivered an assembly that was very long
that's probably usual you know
um so it was we were really looking for
what to cut you know what I'm saying and
and that gave us some really um great
Insight uh in terms of that you know um
in terms of making making trims and I
think it could go wholesale with things
for like that you know they lost them
lost them a bit
um and uh we try to show those cuts
early with like limited music
um you know like just just saw so um
because because you know music
oftentimes has the ability to
make make things that are longer feel
shorter you know
um and we didn't want to to uh uh hide
anything you know like in another
versions so it was helpful in terms of
bringing bringing uh the
making the film more concise Nate
mentioned that you had a number of uh
really cool deleted scenes what do I
need to do to get them either on Disney
Plus or how can I see them yeah I think
it'd be there yeah like once the film is
released on home video you'll see that
you'll see that stuff yeah some great
ones well I was just curious with
deleted since my last question did you
have like 15 minutes of stuff that you
loved like 30 minutes of stuff that you
loved or was it you know I don't have a
number but it was a lot you know I love
basically everything we shot you know
yeah it's always a challenge man
any creative medium is is is the editing
process like what what's it you know
take away what to leave you know yeah
anytime you want to show the Extended
Cut let me know